das ist wirklich eine riesige sensation
forschende haben schwarze löcher
entdeckt die bis zu acht um eine
trillion mal schwerer als die sonne sind
ein absolutes ding der unmöglichkeit
noch ist es eine theoretische entdeckung
aber sie ist alles andere als
unwahrscheinlich und es gibt wieder
einen hinweis darauf was die dunkle
materie sein könnte nämlich nicht
irgendein unbekanntes teilchen links
umsatz im future geht es dreimal pro
woche spannende science videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
so verpasst ihr nächsten los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen bei diesem video ist
übrigens team von astro comics tv
mitarbeit dessen channel ihr unbedingt
abonnieren sollte wenn ihr euch für den
weltraum interessiert ich habe hier oben
und am für euch verlinkt also unbedingt
abonnieren
und jetzt nochmal ein disclaimer ich
verwende den begriff sensation hier
relativ oft und das stört den ein oder
anderen aber ich verwende ihm für
außerordentliche entdeckung oder
außerordentliche wissenschaftliche
erkenntnisse da ich hier über die
herausragendsten phänomene der
wissenschaft berichtet kommt das relativ
auf vor das sensationelle ist in der
wissenschaft ganz normal durch die
revolution der it von computernetzwerken
und prozessoren geschieht das auch immer
öfter es werden immer mehr daten
gewonnen und die immer schneller
miteinander verknüpft dass ihr ständig
sensationelles entdeckt wird ist also
inzwischen nicht mehr die ausnahme
sondern die regel und diese entdeckung
die ist es ganz gewiss nämlich
sensationell eine trillion sonnenmassen
was das für eine unfassbare masse ist
sieht man wenn man sich die masse von
transics welt vor augen führt dass
bisher als das schwerste schwarze loch
im universum galt die u16 weight bringt
nur 66 milliarden sonnenmassen auf die
waage
selbst die un six weight wäre also gegen
die nun postulierten ultra massiven
schwarzen löcher nur ein fliegengewicht
passenderweise gaben die forschenden den
neu entdeckten ungetümen daher auch den
namen stub n des lilas black holes
kurses labs auf deutsch also erstaunlich
große schwarze löcher aber immer der
reihe nach um es zu verstehen ist es
wichtig sich klarzumachen dass es
verschiedene arten von schwarzen löchern
gibt die häufigste art sind sogenannte
stellare schwarze löcher die entstehen
wenn
sehr schwere sterne am ende ihrer
existenz in einer supernova explodieren
damit die rest masse des sterns sich zum
schwarzen noch verdichtet benötigt der
ungefähr 100 sonnenmassen also ziemlich
große sterne nur die wirklich schweren
sterne können also ein schwarzes loch
werden die entwicklung von sternen ist
untrennbar mit der entstehung schwarzer
löcher so verbunden auf diese art und
weise eine kleine einführung in das
thema sternen entwicklung wird euch nun
team vom kanal asto comics tv geben den
ich euch in der infoguard hier oben
verlinkt habe kurzer exkurs zur
sternentwicklung hinter mir seht ihr ein
schaubild der entwicklung eines sterns
es handelt sich nämlich um einen fast
perfekten kreislauf ihr könnt euch
vorstellen sterne entstehen in riesigen
gas nebeln denn eigentlich ist so
normaler haupt rein stern nichts anderes
als eine menge wasserstoff
zusammengequetscht wenn ihr selber mal
ein stern bauen wollte müsste lügen
wasserstoff zusammenpacken und dann
entsteht ein fusionsprozess und zwar
wird in einem normalen stern erstmal
wasserstoff zu helium fusioniert das
heißt der stern durchläuft sein normales
sternen leben wir reden hier von 13
milliarden jahren ungefähr nur
irgendwann ist dann der wasserstoff
vorrat aufgebraucht der stern hat sein
material verfeuert und er zieht sich
etwas zusammen die dichte steigt er
versucht nun die schwereren elemente zu
fusionieren und da die dichte gestiegen
ist kann er das auch nun wird helium
kohlenstoff fusioniert und das nächste
rennen beginnt man nennt das schalen
brennen also wir ja betreten nun die
nächste phase des schalen brems und je
nachdem wie schwer der stern ist kann
das eben weiter und weiter gehen bis
schließlich zum schwersten element dem
eisen da ist dann schluss
und selbst der schwerste stern kommt
eben nicht über das eisen hinaus was am
ende mit dem stern geschieht das hängt
eben ganz von seiner masse ab und sehr
sehr schwere sternen die explodieren
eben als supernova dabei gasen sie aus
und es entsteht ein riesiger gasnebel
sogar ein neutronenstern ihres films
setzt so weit aus diesem gasnebel kann
vielleicht sogar ein neuer stern
entstehen wenn irgendwann noch
zusätzlicher wasserstoff zum beispiel
dazu kommt könnte diese gasnebel wieder
einen fusionsprozesses und deswegen
haben wir eben so eine art kreislauf der
natürlich nicht für immer geht denn
irgendwann ist eben nicht mehr genügend
wasserstoff darum normaler haupt heilen
sterne zu erzeugen weiterhin gibt es
supermassive schwarze löcher diese
ungeheuer lauern im zentrum einer jeden
galaxie und besitzen also fast jeder
galaxie und besitzen meist mehrere
millionen oder sogar milliarden
sonnenmassen im zentrum unserer galaxie
der milchstraße befindet sich auch ein
supermassives schwarzes loch mit dem
namen sagittarius stern obwohl die
massive gravitation dieser schwarzen
löcher furcht einflößen wirkt erfüllen
sie eine wichtige funktion sie halten
durch ihre schwerkraft die galaxien
zusammen unser sonnensystem
beispielsweise rotiert gerade in diesem
moment mit einer geschwindigkeit von 220
kilometern pro sekunde um sagittarius
haben forschende vermuten dass es noch
weitere geheimnisvolle schwarze löcher
gibt und zwar primär die aale schwarze
löcher diese könnten unter den extremen
bedingungen entstanden sein die kurz
nach dem urknall vorherrschten
bisher hat man das nicht für möglich
gehalten oder bekannte solche schwarzen
löcher nicht aber inzwischen gibt es
mehr immer mehr indizien dafür dass es
gibt damals kurz nach dem urknall war
der kosmos noch so unausgegoren dass
sich selbst winzige massen zu schwarzen
löchern komprimiert haben könnten sogar
schwarze löcher mit der masse einer
büroklammer sind laut einigen vorständen
denkbar aber auch riesige schwarze
löcher die gar nicht aus sternen
entstanden sein können wir haben hier
bei pixum darüber exklusiv berichtet
genau das brachte ein team von
astrophysikern und astrophysikerin der
queen mary university in london auf eine
idee wenn die bedingung nach dem urknall
schwarze löcher hervorgebracht haben
könnten dann doch vielleicht auch extrem
schwere schwarze löcher also noch
extremere als bisher schon gefunden
werden kommt die idee der sgs labs war
geboren professor bernhard k der als
astrophysiker an der studie beteiligt
ist äußert sich wie folgt obwohl es
derzeit noch keine beweise für die
existenz von es lab gibt ist es auch
denkbar dass sie existieren und sich
auch außerhalb von galaxien im
intergalaktischen raum aufhalten könnten
was interessante konsequenzen für die
beobachtung des raumes zur folge hätte
wir haben möglichkeiten vorgeschlagen
wie sich diese schwarzen löcher bilden
könnten und hoffen dass unsere arbeit
die diskussion in der wissenschaftlichen
community anregt die forschenden
beließen es nicht bei gedankenspielen
sondern haben die theorie mit modernsten
computern durchgerechnet das ergebnis es
ist absolut wahrscheinlich dass damals
schwarze löcher entstanden sind die alle
uns heute bekannten schwarzen löcher in
sachen größe und masse um ein vielfaches
übersteigen die forschenden erklären
auch wie man sich die entstehung eines
essens vorstellen kann
damals nach dem urteil sind nicht etwa
sterne implodiert und haben schwarze
löcher erzeugt sondern der raum selbst
durch das implodieren und komprimieren
von sogenannten raumzeit taschen ist die
entstehung von schwarzen löchern mit
einem gewicht von einer millionen
sonnenmassen denkbar schwarze löcher die
durch den kollaps von zeit und raum
selbst entstehen
robert k könnten die sgs labs auch ein
baustein für die erklärung der
rätselhafte dunkle materie sein
vorschnell verteufeln ja schon seit
langem an der tatsache dass die galaxien
zu wenig masse besitzen die bekannte
masse der milchstraße beispielsweise
wird überhaupt nicht ausreichen um die
galaxie durch gravitation
zusammenzuhalten es muss daher noch eine
weitere rätselhafte substanz geben die
gravitation ausübt und diese rätselhafte
substanz bezeichnet man als dunkle
materie laut k wäre es denkbar dass die
sgs labs unsichtbar und geheimnisvoll
zwischen den galaxien lauern und durch
ihre ungeheure schwerkraft den dunkle
materie effekt zumindest teilweise
erklären könnten und im fall unserer
galaxie da könnten halt viele schwarze
löcher noch zusätzlich sich in unserer
galaxie unserer milchstraße befinden und
eben diese zusätzliche gravitation
verursachen und es existieren ja auch
gravitationslinsen im universum die
bisher nur durch dunkle materie
erklärbar sind verursachen also es labs
diese linsen also wie gigantisch wäre so
ein es lab in der ausdehnung hier eine
beeindruckende zahl der ereignisse und
also die grenze in der der noch nicht
mal das licht einem schwarzen noch
entkommen kann hätte beim es lag mit
einer trillion sonnenmassen 1
durchmesser von 620.000 lichtern
das wäre also gigantischer als unsere
gesamte milchstraße und das wäre ja auch
genau die größe beobachtete riesiger
gravitationslinsen beziehungsweise das
korreliert damit es wäre ungefähr in
diesem bereich dass ich die e sabs wenn
sie tatsächlich existieren zwischen den
galaxien befinden müssen wir uns wohl
keine sorgen machen dass sie uns
gefährlich werden könnten
forschende haben allerdings
herausgefunden dass uns von einem
anderen schwarzen noch gefahr dar und
könnte unsere erde ist nämlich viel
näher am supermassereichen schwarzen
loch im zentrum der galaxie dran als
bislang gedacht ob das für uns eine
gefahr bedeutet und ob wir bald
eingezogen werden das erklärt euch team
hier in diesem video unbedingt anklicken
anschauen und natürlich us comics tv
abonnieren
damit dabei die 50.000 abos knackt wir
drücken die daumen zeigt also dem
algorithmus oder hammer hängt bis dann
bleibt dran